I've restarted my computer I have
updated to the latest operating system I
did a test recording I made sure the
audio is this mic and not my internal
mic which I had on last time I have my
makeshift mic stand
which is my my fisheye lens what else is
new I broke five thousand subscribers
and I celebrated it with a really buggy
and laggy stream but life is good I
don't think there's any lag let me know
if audio is ok I think thanks to Nathan
Ariel and Excise sparks for just waiting
in the chat the helicopter wait one sec
I think there's a helicopter
[Music]
there's a helicopter I show you people
that's this it's a helicopter
look at that wait is it working no wait
did I just break I just broke the camera
No
okay I'm sorry about that what just
happened is the audio still working I
wanted to show people the helicopter No
okay let me make sure my sound sound
okay you can hear me that's good
but you can't see me because I unplugged
the webcam my copter is flying away
okay let's riad the video
what
delete the video
you
oh no I really hope I'm not breaking
this further
okay I'm gonna riad the video device uh
this one
you
you
and it didn't work what's going on I
wonder if I actually like just broke my
webcam
properties
okay well
this will have to know this is bad
quality
and now it's just completely lagging
oh man
why did a helicopter
have to fly over and just completely
distract me
okay let me make sure everything is
plugged in properly
okay
there we go
I'm fullscreen
so people can get it behind-the-scenes
look what it takes the frame myself
and by frame myself I mean
not actually frame myself literally just
visually okay I think that looks okay
quality isn't so bad just in the corner
what's in the corner
move it maybe move it this way mmm okay
whatever we'll leave it like this we'll
accept some challenges these are all new
names
I'm gonna play Kluth because he's a
patron
good luck Ruth
that was a bit discomforting there was a
little bit of lag there but okay yeah I
feel free to challenge me feel free to
ask questions do we already get one
question I mean the like when I'm
playing a game I'm gonna try and stay
focused on the game we'll see how that
goes
good luck to my opponent I'm gonna play
I'll play a semi Slav nevermind trades
I don't think trading is the best
the trading on d5 isn't supposed to be
played soberly in that position because
now I have Bishop f5 usually he should
play it
when is that five wouldn't be possible
I guess he still has Queen c2 though he
really wants to prevent Bishop f5
wait Ariel mentioned something about
something I see the end game position I
did not see the end game position you
linked
to link it again was it in a message or
was it in the chat cuz I wasn't looking
at the cats of beating up to the stream
okay he plays Bishop f4 I think I'll
just play Bishop f5 and in this specific
position I believe Queen b3 can be met
with b5 and even like a5 a4 ideas okay
so we're going to complete developments
you
soon
which is better long short or medium
castle what is medium castle of course
it depends on the position sometimes you
shouldn't castle all in this position I
think both sides are going to Castle
shorts
this has some resemblance to a London
like my bishop my knight other knights
coming here I could play Queen b6 at
some points if I want I'm gonna Castle
first stay flexible
we continue to stay flexible
in positions like this sighs a couple
ideas for whites one idea is to play
some rookie 894 another idea starts with
rook e8 and then Knight f8 and 96 or or
Knight g6 but okay now my pawn is going
to be on g6
I'll still go for rookie 8 very soon
hello to our our Hyde
so few vowels
and that name
okay I'll play Ricky
now I can't play 94 right away so I'll
probably go for this fun this and then
maybe even Bishop d6 because this is
just a passive Bishop this is more
active Bishop so it makes sense
and is she at that trade and then like
really long-term my idea would be to
eventually play G v g6 King g7 rook h8
and then g4 and break down the H file
that's gonna take a long time though and
whites long-term plan is minority
attacking with b4 b5 which is a much
quicker plan well okay let's start with
my enough aids there's still lag I don't
know why
at least with moving the pieces I don't
think there's lag in the video though so
he plays b4 I'm gonna play 96 because it
comes with initiative on the bishop I'm
expecting Bishop g3 or Bishop h2
and then I'm probably gonna play a six
because white would like to play a four
and then B five immediately but he can't
play a four right away because before is
hanging so it's going to take one extra
move
by vision t6 most likely
stream quality seems fine that's what I
like to hear
okay so Rick b1
a v1
we wants to play a four
this is a very common structure for
anyone who plays like Queens gambit
declined this is what we call the
Carlsbad structure
I think Carlsbad is actually a town in
the Czech Republic which I found out
like just a few days ago it's like a
good place to get a spa but
the Carlos bad position usually features
this minority attack where black either
wants to prevent it or go for play on
the Keen side so our our hide is asking
what other plans and this King side
attack are available for black in this
structure
well we might find out because I don't
know if I'm gonna get a king-size attack
95 is slightly annoying move normally I
would like to challenge the night with
97 but that hangs upon or does it hang
upon so I can take on each to it check
maybe it doesn't hang up home he could
play at 4:00 there
so 97 f4
hmm
I'm also tempted to play g5
to try and discourage f4 I'd also may be
considering some g4 possibilities
you
you
one scary thing I see with g5 is he
could play Queen f5 but then I could
play g6 I think things are under control
now maybe that's just another plan like
g5g six King g7 Merc h8
so let's do it
so try and answer the question further
what other plans are black for black are
there in this position occasionally
there's b5 to close down the Queen side
and then like somehow get a Knight to c4
maybe with this maneuver
there's also certain ideas when light
does go for the attack the minority
attacked either open the C file or the a
file
but sometimes these positions it can be
hard to find like a very clear plan
especially if white plays restrictively
you explained the goals of the minority
attack when you get some downtime in the
scheme
okay well I think it's downtime also
thanks for the bits hero or no Nathan
why did I say hero is hero here
I think heroes here
um here is always with here with us in
spirit well there goes my downtime but
white wants to play b5 and and weakened
uh the pawns especially the c6 pawn
if white creates a backward C pawn it
could be on the half-open file and that
would be
that would be in Mike's favor
b5 now because there's a knight on e5
attacking c6
but maybe I could because there's
tactics with h2
seems shaky
okay considering three moves on
considering G 697 and b5
maybe I could also consider taking an e5
this feel feels wrong though
if I play 97 does that actually have a
threat
also consider g4
maybe it does have a threat if I play 97
I'm threatening Queen c7 he's kind of
pressurized
just don't like giving up the fence over
d5 as well as g4
I'm considering a move here which is
kind of admitting mistake I'm
considering Knight f8
also just considering g6 what source
that can happen after g6 b5 train and a5
okay I'm gonna play g6 I'm gonna keep
all the tension I'm not going to make
any of my pieces worse
I do have a plan of king g7 I'm not I
don't think I'm scared of this because I
have 97 in the end
b5 is probably the critical line and
it's very common in these minority
attack positions for black to respond
with to be five with C take B 5 8 8 B 5
and then a 5 getting a passed upon and
not getting a weakness on c6
so I'm going to do that pretty quickly
because I don't want to get a long time
and then maybe I'll play b6 I could be
weakening to the square so to be a
little bit careful maybe I'll just put a
truck on the c8 for my King on g7
I think things are controlled relatively
like Bishop before ideas
ha the pawn bishop duo could be nice
Ruby 6 so you also play this
but that seems overextending
I'm just gonna play rook c8 just another
quick move based on intuition my a
five-point could be weak but I always
have there should be four if necessary
and meanwhile Bishop e4 might be a
tactical threat is c3 I mean I might
have a few threats here in Bishop b4 and
94 I'm a bit concerned the lag is gonna
be getting worse but even when I draw
arrows
starts to lag I don't know why it wasn't
doing that
in the past
anyway I'm up on time he's thinking
a lot more dynamic now
I just read me it's common what do we do
with past pawns
I mean I have a passed pawn I don't
think I'm gonna push it even though
that's what you're supposed to do with
past pawns
I'm probably just gonna defend it with
my bishop um so it doesn't get taken
what is he gonna do here yes to remove
his Queen probably yeah maybe I
shouldn't have told him that now he's
attacking d5 so I think it's time for a
bishop before and now I'm attacking the
Knights I'm defending my pawn and I'm
obstructing his queen so I'm maybe
attacking this fun as well
is happening
am i doing games with viewers yes this
is the first viewer actually I don't
know if this is a viewer you just
challenging me I assume he's watching oh
he's a ok oh people can't see the chat
he's a fellow IHSA participant let me do
a poll how many people in the chat know
what IHSA is and how it relates to chess
I'm just curious as I know there's a few
a few people out there who come from IHS
a route to findt thanks for the follow
so now if I take on v6 he takes on
before and that's a trade
I mean what else can I consider though
don't think there's too many options I
could repeat Bishop e7
Bishop back to d6
b7 is left weak
but what else to do I have an
interesting move Knight e4 threatening
92 94 and I take before 92 the Queen has
to move I take on f1 this night and his
Bishop are hanging
let's do it I'm not gonna double-check
the line there's also a line where I can
just take oh no I can't cuz he defends
okay so I'm relying on ninety two and
he's thinking or I'm making him think
she's kind of what I want and the beauty
of ninety two he can't stop it because
it's a triple fork he can only remove
one of the three pieces and then he'll
still get double for it uh except I
forgot about 903 who's backward Night
Moves so easy to forget about them
three is a candidate move
I feel like g4 is really interesting
like g4
take g4 and then night six g5 just
wanting to remove the night and if he
takes I have all these threats let's do
it
time is getting low again relying on
some intuition
but he's under pressure like every move
I'm keeping initiative we can pre move
something
you
spawned to this
is it rude to respond to the opponent
when there sometime shovel just forgot
to respond to his message
okay so yeah this night is like a key
defender and it's going to get traded or
chased away
let's keep the pre-move
whoa okay so now I can take with Chuck
and then play 92
the screen has to move
take on f1 or he could take on d5
still working the rooks okay going for
this line hopefully it works out
I'm currently down a pawn and the bishop
but he has a lot of things hanging he
has one too he has up so many things
hanging Queen d3 so now do I take on f3
and then go for some like eventual Queen
h4 Queen date g4
that looks devastating for him
I could also just take the rook can be
up to exchange for a pawn or for two
pawns maybe
I think taking on f3 is just crushing
though because I'm gonna have King g7
and rook h8 amend
he can save as nights
this is so confusing
nice one
take
three kingi - I went G four okay I'm
gonna take on that three it wasn't my
original plan but I think it leads to an
easier position to play
I think blacks should be better
because pawns are now equal I take care
he can't act to take back on each two
but he can move his knight but his
knight doesn't really have any squares
unless he wants to I mean he has to go
back to one of these two squares both of
which are really depressing that I'm
gonna take on g4 I'll be up upon with
superior Knights and the King side
attack elastic hold Junior are you the
real elastic hold or are you the younger
brother of elastic hold who spend my
chat once so curious who this is or
maybe it's just an imposter
okay so he's going for a counter play
let's play Queen g5 and non-threatening
double check
King f3 will remove
this is playable
looking for kind of moves may be a
rookie six
we work e6 rookie it looks
looks to be adding the pressure
you
but I assume this is strong
and then taking
still relying on intuition and I can
take here wait maybe I should rely on
calculation okay he just resides I guess
I could just take the night I was
searching for mates they take e3 and
then kingi one Marissa mate
it's somewhere there a nice game Kluth
yeah that was an interesting interesting
example of the Carlsbad structure from
qgd
something's definitely slower today I
don't know what it is I've closed all my
tabs
maybe OBS is being slowing things down
but we had some yeah we had some typical
Carlsbad I'm thinking that maybe I
should have played this first
da six and then - of g6 I guess it
worked out yeah I think this idea is
maybe not intuitive for a lot of players
it's something to kind of know about
before running into a minority attack
but when light goes for this break it's
useful to note to take away from the
center and then get the past a pawn
he's in Queens egg d5 instead of Queens
III GG let me go to that position
we have once OH cron line Queen take d5
hmm
I guess I just assumed I would win the
exchange
maybe not
or maybe he's just getting an absurd
number of pawns this is a funny line
like if night egg f1 I assume Queen's
egg d8 rip take TAS can take take take
black is not better here I would still
play for a win but black is not better
because White has
I has four pawns for the for the
exchange okay maybe I wouldn't play for
a win but sometimes these positions you
have to play for a win otherwise you you
play for a loss
you have to like coordinate the rooks on
the first or second rank
I just say for I can't count why does up
three pawns I struggle with counting
these this giant clump of pawns really
confused me
okay yeah let's move on Nathan thanks
for the bits
ah new new person I have my phone with
me are people hearing feedback on the
mic because my phone is really closed
close by
give me a random number between 1 and 8
- ok x/i sparks getting a game
like I'm sorry for that
what did I want to play the other day
that I didn't get the chance to play
Belgium novice
I should have more math insights like
that okay exercise Forex is turning the
stream off so I don't have to hold back
in my thoughts and he's flying a French
what about opening the French is
actually a playable opening which I have
to remember what to do against
let's just play b3 this is a weird line
which I studied at some point in my life
of ideas to play Bishop b2
there's actually many lines where light
develops the whole Queen side and Queen
side castles before touching the king
side if you looked anymore at the Queen
c7 line in London um only briefly I only
looked at some possibility of white
playing f4 early I have not looked too
deeply okay he's transposing to a
Sicilian which is very playable this is
now a b3 Sicilian
Gotham chess recommends b3
the French
hmm yeah b3 is a tricky line
there's a strong bishop let's treat this
like a Grand Prix and play f4 9 f3 maybe
even like Bishop b5
yeah the London died after h5 I moved to
so we'll have to find a counter to that
first
see three I guess it's also a five but I
don't want to kill my bishop too quickly
very tempted here if you if he makes it
possible for me to play some early g4
that might be hard to resist
we'll see what he does
Wow
well I can't play or can I play G for me
back together way with G for
promise you can take with the night
the problem
I don't think it's a problem I'm gonna
go for it because it just looks like a
really interesting position the chess
guide to underscore zero thanks for the
follow
yeah this might be overly weird
and sometimes when you start the game
off wearily you have to continue weirdly
so one of my rationales is that after he
takes with ideas of Queen h4 I can take
back and if Queen h4 immediately add
night g3 he's going for this let's light
it just assume g5 when I take back in
the other line if he were to take take
take I was going to consider h4 her
preventing Queen h4 then maybe g5 at
some points and then probably when the e
pawn back but okay I wouldn't
oh I don't an e pawn because he wins F
pawn
but maybe that's okay because when I
start getting initiative in I take you
for denied a guy for queen up three
56 Bishop b5 a file opens actually lots
of things open my Bishop's open
yeah he's gonna he's gonna need some
bravery if he wants to take on f4
it was if he allows Queen f3 where
there's there's so many targets for
white okay let's see what happens it's
important to note my knight defends g5
so there's no Queen jg5 Bishop d6 was my
original and first thought for a black
but that would hang g7 of g7 hangs on f6
was weak meanwhile his Knights attacks I
want to play Bishop b5 and gather rook
to f1 the target f7
so night okay let's play Bishop b5
you
you
I can't complain with this position it's
weird still but I'm down upon my bishops
are happy my Center is happy
I think both his bishops are actually
not having the best time developing but
Bishop d7 is a natural move yeah now he
wants to play Knight e5
which is a bit irritating
even 94 could be irritating
you
you
I'm actually considering 9 f6 here
promises night on this night on g6
accidentally defends as a rock on a
chick on h8 so nigh of six would give
away two pieces for a rook
which probably would not be good
there's also this move I didn't consider
which actually is starting to look very
strong
I'm calculated a bit more
I don't know how it works so is Bishop
to g7
Bishop take G 796 87
I don't think it works
they take on f7 take on g7 the Miss King
finds shelter what else to consider is
Bishop f6 that's also probably not
working
so I'm actually considering just a very
boring move here
which is Queen g3
Knight e5
my Queens Arthur I file
maybe I just screen sigh castle or maybe
just
ninety-two
tonight move I take on g7
and then queen g3
initiative
okay I'm gonna play I'm gonna play
queenside castle
because I think it's the most flexible
and who a6
honestly didn't see that coming but now
I have work off one
uh with a me threat
I still have to consider all these weird
lines with bishop take g7 nine f6 Bishop
f6
rook f1 mainline 95 take on g7 take on
thee seven
that's night ge5 I'd have to take on e5
and then take on the southern and queen
a foreign land
okay go for it
a Benjamin
1995 95 if you want a challenge or if
you want to play me challenge me on me
chess and I think the way I'm doing it
I'm just asking Siri for a random number
and then after every game I will choose
a new random number and that determines
who I play I currently have 12 pending
challenges
so there is some hope
weights getting better here
let's take your first
Queen f6 would be a funny move probably
just bad
when g3 queen g3 or queen f4 or Bishop
to g5 and then Queen at four
you'll play queen g3 keep all the
tension I really want to keep my bishop
I'll give up on attacking that fallin
for a little bit what would you
recommend against this with black are
you singing against b3 French or against
b3 Sicilian normally against b3 Sicilian
because I'm the Sicilian player myself I
like to play b6 oh no what do I do
no okay there we go that was slightly
terrifying I do their switch windows
it's okay now
yeah I usually like something very
quiets against b3 because usually be
three players are a bit crazy like like
crew 64 or Gotham chess whatever his
name is
um queen c6 while so he's
counter-attacking
so if I take
tics
the servicing and lyric is hanging
I'm thinking I complain that f3 here I
play 9 f3
he takes I take life is good no three
he takes I take he takes I take
life is also good okay go with this
oh he is saying be three Sicilian yeah I
usually play B 6 e 6 Bishop be 786
usually go for something like Hedgehog
setup
how long have I had the YouTube channel
I've actually had it a long time I just
haven't been active on it until recently
until basically doing twitch and just
putting archives twitch stuff on there
and somehow like the last month to two
months
the audience has just grown
exponentially I have no idea what caused
it it may have been just a few like
popular videos but yeah it's good to see
they say that bishop I take of night
take care as kings in the center whoa I
forgot about that move
just assumed I was hitting f7
okay this is actually terrifying
are you have Queen f2
anyway
a rookie one
I've may take g6 bishop take g3 and I
take h8
for Bishop to g7
I have to find the least of the evils
is d3
I'm gonna play rookie one
like this is the safest move
you
pressure I want to keep my darks for
Bishop
I'm sorry for people's ears really sorry
about that I'm just trying to
reconfigure my windows
everything's so big
so weird
you
okay
you
okay focus on the game I'm low on time
but I have enough time and there's two
second comments mean F for
that feels like a plunger can I just
take on g6
oh then he takes back with pawn with
each pawn I take on g7
I can win the pond deck
maybe that's what I want from the pond
deck
why not
maybe make him think
lots of stuff is attacked here oh I
don't think that's a good move by him
take and now there's a pin so if you
take spear I win both are I win my rook
if he takes here I take here or I take
on g7 first
I probably take on g7 first
yes I play this and then I play this and
then this is hanging and this is hanging
and this King is stuck in the center
okay life is much better now
good position also who is Jack see Jack
see iix back Roman numerals Jack see iix
the game I wanted you to analyze is
between go links burg and night earth or
saw 1928 it's the 24th game and Kasparov
mind gray this private predecessors wait
I I don't want to flag while reading
that comments also I'm winning in a
piece
also
jacksie thanks for the hundred or the
thousand bits
competing with Nathan
he's trying to analyze it and whisper
I'm sure be sure I would do a better job
you've memorized the game okay off to
take a look
I know if I'll take a look during the
stream because I'm like things are
lagging I feel like opening up a study
actually maybe it wouldn't be any
different
but there's 19 cunning challenges I
might do that if you want me to do it
for like a YouTube video let me make a
note of this before I forget
I'll just screenshot screenshot okay
the comment has been captured
and the champ thanks for the follow
oh you're not done analyzing on HS okay
cool
send me a message
send me a message if I don't reply send
me another message sometimes you have to
be persistent any tips for playing first
tournament this weekend get a lot of
sleep sleep and diet and physical
well-being is a lot more important than
any sort of chess preparation especially
if the tournament is less than a week
away then you want to do things which
will improve your mind and your body
more so than just crowning like opening
theory or whatever or solving tactics
that's my best advice also jacksie
thanks for the sub appreciate that
that's the first sub of today
you play Halloween next Benjamin thanks
for the follow
Halloween gambits
could try Halloween Gavin is a hard
opening sometimes get into
quit d3 controlling a lot of squares
around his kingdom
jacksy cheered a thousand bits and then
subbed and then followed to great a
great order
okay I'm gonna play I'm gonna move my
King into the center and we'll try and
like get some meeting nets with the king
the pawns
serve with c4
I don't know how I'm gonna meet with
just so few I don't think I have enough
pieces maybe I do
Brook
or he seven Antonio fat tone thanks for
the follow c4 is explosive
King is almost stalemated but he does
have an a pawn and now I see my
checkmates and because he's not watching
the stream my secret plan is this and
then this with meat so
keep pushing you're a pawn
play a four
first
no need to think they play a three
you can do it
is
or rookie six would be nice either move
ooh
Rick c5 okay so he played the best move
but now I play d4 d4
he can do anything
and I think it's unstoppable mate just a
couple more moves
can can't move
yeah pass phones must be pushed but this
freeze I'm pushing the SI phan for the
reason that i'm i'm obstructing his rook
from controlling the ultimate mating
square if he didn't have an a pawn that
would be sale made so thank god he has
an a pawn uh Gigi I was definitely worse
at some point at some point in that game
just to demonstrate I think if he plays
go to analysis board if he plays d5
this is why I'm saying with analysis for
it it's just it's my computer
something's wrong
but if this were to happen
there's weird ideas like if Knight f6 is
g4 and this is actually playable
like this is a masters database - so
there's been games here anyway
wait could people see that or it was my
face blocking oh no people can see
everything oh okay yeah but that game
[Music]
I was expecting they take e4 after which
this because I've gotten really weird so
I for I think he played well 95 at the
right time and then this is all fine
I was thinking that he should take on e5
we may be able to take back with the
bishop
and when g7 so you played Queen at four
and I think this was the worst mistake
of the game where he you took on g3 I
think H 86 it's just better
avoiding the Queen trade and now
probably just better here just because
if we trade Queens
both of these pawns are weak I could
take on g7 but I think it's gonna help
botch should still be doing well here
anyway
I'm using Chrome
is a browser the issue because I
couldn't
can she switch
but
I don't know now the lag seems to be
okay
but yeah this lag okay well when I play
a game hopefully it's not too annoying I
have 24 pending challenges
okay give me a random number between 1
and 25 16 16 okay now I have to count
see how my counting abilities hold up 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so nathan is 10 okay
that's a good marker 11 12 13 14 15 left
below 3 2 blitz okay let's do it
X villager with the sub gifted by Nathan
thanks Nathan
thanks ox villager axe villager in the
chat
missing every critical moments of my
life the lack could be really annoying
with what so now there's no more lag
let's play Bishop e5
and then Bishop c4
this is some sort of line I think
link b5 the move like be 585
five okay now I'm going to hold on to
the pond or as long as I can
you
might not be too long but I'll still try
I'm going to try and play that s4 hi fer
thanks for the follow now I have another
check
as bishop is moving so many times making
it dizzy
to do
we just trade everything okay I have a
sigh I wanna call it a dumb trap but
it's somewhat of a hopeful trap
and it's not at all gonna work I'm gonna
try it anyway
it's assuming he takes on d5
you
he's thinking here maybe he won't take
as I could remove this
number one okay he doesn't even flinch
um yeah Queen och3 so the trap is that
if he plays a six life will be very good
he plays c6 of course and now life is
just equal
and this is free - this could be a hard
position to win Jacob but Lee thanks for
the son
you
but actually okay there's a lot of life
in this position a lot of ways to try
and create imbalances that's usually the
way I try and beat lower rated players
is by creating
creating some imbalances in the position
whether it be material imbalance
okay so okay he's just attacking me
let's play let's play g3
this position there's a space imbalance
main-sequence 12 thanks for the follow
earth for the sub and thanks to Nathan
for gifting the sub
okay now I just have more space Nathan
so generous today
gifting 13 subs so unlucky
you
you castles queenside okay this is gonna
make things fun should probably defend
the pawn
now I'm gonna do this and he's going to
do this we'll see you this quicker
this is f5 but the knight on c5 what do
they call this 95
now e6 is the target so mr. Tackett how
does he defend
you can play rook aged six
but then I think I can take on that five
not going to check that I'm just going
to assume it works
I don't think isn't he like bailing out
Queen moves
I apologize for nightbot being maybe
overly strict
all caps messages should be okay if
they're appropriate
um okay there's a pen here and there's a
ton of pressure ie six
by a ton of pressure I mean three
attackers I know I think I can just take
with the rook
the position is crumbling
chess is fun when you have a position
like this a pod
yeah we're just trading trade Queens
light will be up to pawns and it's a
triple fork
you
I could take g7
rookie two is coming okay let's take c7
King f1
I'm gonna be boring just gonna simplify
and be up to pawns or not hey it's a sub
it's a sub that's not gifted by anything
such an odd occurrence boy Sandvik 94
appreciate that
visit a better home
or an even better home
is even play c5
the place e5
but then he's walking into a pin
and now mr. retreats or just keep the
rook active
Kaji master thanks for this thanks for
the sub or that follow it's so difficult
to distinguish subs and follows
I need more interesting alerts
who's what's been happening more today
subs are follows so hard to keep track
okay I'm gonna play rook d6 let's try
another mating that in the center of the
board
and this position is ripe for for some
kind of meaning that it's going to
require my king so let's put the king on
you two
you
so play king r5
hard to stop so I'll play King us three
you
interesting
you
I'm trying too hard to mates
or is coming
okay I'll play h3 I'm trying to scourge
g4 so I'll play G for myself ooh
okay well now as king house no squares
all I have to do is check his King and
not give him any free squares to move to
but how did I do that
hmm
mates
oh I see I see some trick it relies on
hope but I have hope
but still not meat
you
okay he hung his rook that's nice okay a
couple a couple similar games these rook
Bishop mating patterns sad finish for
him uh what is this line analysis board
I'm just curious about the opening not
this far though probably after just
after Bishop f5 like what's the theory
Knight c3
ninety-seven
so there's very few games now me
chasse's a lot more games
just looking at what scores the highest
like G - scores decently
Queen f3 could be interesting
okay something to look into further
um let's move on give me a random number
between 1 and 24 16 again 16 well thanks
for the bits boy Sandvik test please
ignore her
okay I managed to not ignore that I'm
sorry okay 16 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
Oh Nathan's eighth now 9
Oh Sandvik is 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 what's your name
I don't want to hurt myself pronouncing
this name but good luck whoever you are
the second time in a row Siri chooses 16
at least some kind of conspiracy
okay
I have to end the stream before this
ramen place closes they better not
already be closed ramen and our okay
I'll take opening suggest our opening
recommendations so let me know an
opening to play against D for that
starts with 906 can you play perc I
can't play perc against e4
I could play King's Indian
but benoni known as possible
check benoni what's oh let's check
benoni is that checkpoint on the NC 4
and E 5 I believe I'm gonna play the
check benoni that's a great
recommendation
great and ramen place is open for two
more hours takes a half hour to get
there
yeah I'll figure out when to end the
stream
I hope check Mahoney is a 5 is checked
by nominee the same thing as a Feingold
Benoni
it is
thanks for the bits who ever cheered I
have no idea who cheered oh this isn't
the Nathan sheer 100 bits for g5
I don't think so g5 is not a move I want
to play
I should know the history here but why
do they call it the Czech Benoni
do Czech players actually play this
now I'll admit to watching been flying
goal lectures I remember some lecture he
gave on this exact opening and I was
saying something about Anand with this
plan of like 98 and then eventually f5
so that's what I'm gonna do and we'll
see what happens
I don't understand each three
suspicious move
I wonder if playing the Czech benoni
makes you like turn into Ben Feingold
so I've already said suspicious it's
slightly concerning or just terrible
I honestly don't know if I was
like I five immediately or prepare it
also not sure where this night is
supposed to go is usually at gooden's
here but sometimes it can come here here
and support b5 ok night g7 only way to
not lose a rook
I like the fact that he's thinking
now I'm gonna treat this very slowly I'm
gonna be very patient I might be playing
too slow
but I don't know what White's plan is
and I'm kind of just waiting to figure
out while I just improved my pieces okay
he wants to play d4 maybe you really
want to play b4
seems odd now I think it's good time to
play this
this rook is on b1 and if he takes on
that five I could take the bishop
also my not on c7 serves some purpose in
making sure a six isn't too weak even
though I do have three pieces
controlling a six
this is actually not a bad opening for
like Blitzer rapid just because ideas
for black are so straightforward it's
just like you want to play f5 or b5 or
both
meanwhile lights white house like an
impressive space advantage but not
always clear what what wants to do
I have a feeling he's already missplay
that a little bit so I think white is
supposed to go for D for earlier or F
for earlier
you
okay he's below five minutes isn't b-6
called the modern difference
I know it b6 is called actually g6 is a
modern why is Eric playing terrible
openings today terrible I mean I think
this is the least terrible opening I've
played so far
well their game was be three French
there's another game
was other game
Oh other game with Scandinavian which is
also not that impressive for me okay I'm
gonna play f4 because this is now
turning into some Kings Indian structure
and now his bishop sorry about the mic
just slaps the mic but
staying on the stand
at some point he's going to take on g7
I'll get the bishop here
maybe six
I think what I'll do I'll play a very
typical Kings Indian move which is rook
f7 but in this case it's the idea comes
with idea to move the Knights so those
bishops just staring at nothing and
we'll see we'll see if he takes or if
he's very vinod to leave his Bishop on
h6 oh he's so grave
now I was thinking
she wants to play rugby aids
he wants to play rugby and maybe I just
play Bishop d7 Nathan wants g5 in this
position g5 is actually not a bad move
but oh let me play it when the time
feels right
I'm trying to not I'm trying not to look
at the chat too much in terms of what
moves people are suggesting because I
don't want any unfair hints
[Music]
so let me try and use
my own brain
what does Queen c2 I don't know what
he's doing
we just play a quick move
I'm not playing 98
getting my night off attack of the
bishop also if I play 9 h5 it could be
targeted by his Bishop and now g5 could
be more realistic
I'm still not seeing a continuation
five nine words
you
maybe g5g for would be natural okay he's
trying to scare me but I have no fear
I'll play Queen CAS maybe I'll go for
some sack
and then maybe this isn't even a sack
now I'm realizing it this could be the
way to trap is Bishop
as in this sort of line
I think I would have queen G for messy
though
I think that would be good
do I live in st. Louis I will live in
st. Louis
starting on what's today this is a 20-6
starting on the 31st I will be living in
st. Louis temporarily and the singer is
this M singers and tree into the chat
thankfully I'm singer you you came at
the right time after Nathan disabled the
like all caps prevention with night box
as earlier my thought was just deleting
messages with all all caps
um
you
I was taking away the our freedom of
speech
but if I okay if I take King g7 and then
I want to play h6 this Bishop is just
like honor
know how he stops us oh he could play
this and then maybe I sack
crazy position
you
sultanim sack thanks for the follow
life is good I have a threat I don't
know if he can stop it I should probably
be calculating because f3 makes the most
sense and then if I take take take
I'm threatening h6 and you can't escape
via h4
this bishop f1
Bishop f1 queen g3 Queen G to h6 we
trade
he plays Bishop h4 I take on f3 and I'm
threatening the night and I'm
threatening g5
I'm going to trust my intuition here
you
so the line I calculated is this this
okay never mind
deep calculation for nothing so now I
can retreat and I'm up up on
he's saving his bishop but now I'll have
some kind of pawn storm
this game is good but is life really
good I mean this game is my life for the
next few minutes so yes
Exce villager I'm not going to play
Queen me one anytime soon at least
my next several moves are moving the
pawns
side pawns must be pushed and the fact
that he doesn't have in each pond could
really hurt him in like five or ten more
moves because it's just a bit less
shelter for his king
and this is just painful position for
for whites this black is having all the
fun
Geoffrey Chi 20 2009 thanks for the
follow
I'm gonna trot my queen he's gonna play
Queen B 1 then rook be AIDS and Queen
this force to a6 which i think is okay
let's continue with h5
if I want I could like runs the kingside
okay so is rook b8 in actual threats
or can I make a counter threats
or can I just play that a six stop it
and be happy
I like 9006 because it requires very
little thoughts I just see I control the
eights
I'll make him think and now I am
controlling these squares so there's no
real entry points anywhere
and then I can start focusing on my
kingside play
slowly improve like king g6 I think is
slightly about our square for the King
off of the seventh rank
I'm how else can i slowly improve
considering each for first
each for h3
let's do it
this is one of his problems not having
an H pawn it's a fact that in a position
like this he would love to play h3 and
close things down but I'll always have
this looming pawn break
work here
do I have tactics no not
okay I'll put the rook here probably put
the knight on G three let's play this
I can open the H file
that would be nice
can't open aids file
courses open
let's open it
so he ran this King to see one but his
King is still going to be a target
because I'm just in bathing
the issues is this Rick is just so sad
what to do I have night before here and
some of I forgot about it looks
incredibly strong as it cuts off the
defense of the rook on b7 and I just win
this who he can take on c5 though
I have to live with my decisions
I think I'm getting some additional
breakthrough
maybe not
but I'm up material his pawns are scary
though a weird position
he saves safe places for the bishop by
him up a ton of time c5
Oh
what's going on here
your moves come to mind
f1
just a bit worried about no I think it's
okay Bishop f1 uh I think he would have
to trade nine take f1 Queen G - then I
moved back to g3 I throw anyone
that's okay
meanwhile I'm just threatening to win a
piece
I'm attacking him from the rear which is
always nice
if he doesn't play Queen g2 I'll play 93
create the pin I attack the bishop
- flag how much it would have been
interesting if the game continued that I
was probably going to take the pawn next
still a little bit scary his two
connected passers and this immaculate
pawn chain
thanks jack see for the cheer recording
something which know if I'm happy I said
but do you appreciate the hundred bits
um well that was my check benoni played
in the Czech Republic
not sure if Feingold would be pleased or
suspicious of me
one thing I played too terribly Salaam
cam thanks for the follow or if thanks
for the sub so confusing subs and
follows
okay give me a random number between
give me a random number between 1 and 27
the answer is B team just like in
between numbers where I have to count it
C so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so Stevie's
time
or it's TV go
okay 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 okay for it
perfect
it was f mom b mm thanks for the sub
though if to tie Nathan of course and
bogdan's J thanks for the sub I
appreciate all you all you amazing
people
what am I playing what did someone want
earlier
I knew any opening recommendations like
the first recommendation
phone good luck anyone give me a give me
an opening I'm waiting
before okay at least mighty Marcus was
not is not quick enough I'm playing the
Polish chess individual again wants me
to play a pub appears as white
I know if this guy is here we'll give
him ten seconds
I took longer to play b4
org tweeted my mind stream pleasant
surprise okay we have a game
now play
we play up all this doesn't happen too
often
main idea of the polis who do I
for dirtiness I'm going for dirtiness
wait no I haven't played the e3 yet
though so the h4 is just a random move
well now I go for e3 ah he saw it okay
still going for the dirtiness
to be very quiet ah he saw it's okay
well now we have a game uh let's defend
the pond for those of you who don't know
what I was referring to only a few days
ago I discovered this trap against the
London which I've been playing maybe a
bit too bit too loosely this h4g for
trap
um I don't mind this position that I
provoked h5 I have a nice g5 square to
work with this looks okay but the night
on g5 and the coordination between the
bishop and night other bishop attacking
h5 rook
developing a fuel for these positions
anonymous just subscribed
why does it say anonymous but then it
shows the name of the user in the chat
or just does it just show it for me
I appreciate the sub anonymous I want to
say your actual name off thank you
you
also this is 3/2 so I have to move much
quicker
Splatt for
for I think is a typical move for these
structures nice pawn chain I'm just
gonna retweet b ches org they're so nice
to me
retweets
I know if I mentioned this earlier but I
wanted to do a YouTube livestream to
celebrate the 5000 subscribers but I
didn't want to take the time to figure
out YouTube's live streaming platform so
that we'll probably have to wait and so
a bigger moment in my life do I take
I think I can take I can't take a bunch
of times and when age five because a one
would be hanging
okay I'm gonna take them once drive
aways bishop
then g4 looks fun
you
the definition of a pond storm
then pieces working together
subscribed what is this
Oh Nathan sub with a Tier three weight
is up better than tier 1
I think that is
well thank you Nathan Tier three sub I
don't think I have too many of those
also I think we've we've probably hit 50
subs because I was on the verge before
this stream
and by 50 subs I'm not talking about
YouTube unfortunately or fortunately I'm
talking about twitch which means I'm
gonna get another emote so if anyone
wants to give emote suggestions Oh
Korean sub count 46 but tier 3 subs
count as more per sub points I think
get out later
this is e4 it's blocking my bishop
I could play e4 black his bishop
but each five
okayyyy for hangs upon let's play h5
first belgium novice emote Photoshop
stream coming that's true actually
Photoshop will probably make my computer
lag a lot more than it's already lagging
so
maybe some sort of like broken computer
email also on into London emotes I
wanted a G for emotes maybe I'll just
put together like a poll I'll have a
Twitter poll of the top like top floor
that people asked for our ramen emote
common sounds good
you're making me hungry
for you
f-five looks reasonable
six no age six looks unreasonable
I want to take that opens the e-file
of f3 just be very calm attack b7 and
throw a knee for
and play quickly
and complete development
you
and get out of check
and thank you jacksie for more bits
chess is way more important than hunger
defend my bishop let's advance upon
to
put him in check go for the kill
always retreats ooh
see - singing
see to
can't really defend it let the king on
f2 it's a safe place and my rook is
gonna come to g1 and look at this
pressure just so beautiful everything
okay he's defending mate
mmm can't get too excited too soon
each six books - too strong
I don't see how he's gonna defend I'm
pretty sure this is force mates
okay that was a nice finish and strong
attack
it took some patience like earlier I was
trying to attack crops prematurely
without my whole queenside developed and
then I developed my queen side and then
the attack was so much easier i drugged
me okay uh well I am up to thirty
pending challenges so Siri give me a
random number between one and thirty
well Nathan was ten earlier one two
three four five six seven eight
wait I lost count one two three four
five six seven eight okay it's Stevie
Stevie
where's Stevie good luck Stevie and good
luck to excise sparks or Oh for his
lunch and thanks for the game x-eye
sparks as a fun game
I was okay I I can count to ten I don't
have trouble counting to ten it's just
when I'm with my computer is laggy and
I'm using my mouse account it's
difficult um what did people say before
someone wanted a perk whoever wants a
perk or it's it's supposed to be
pronounced Pierce I'm playing appearance
against e4 I'm gonna play g6 it's
probably going to transpose to a king's
indian unless he plays some weird it's
playing some colleague tour a1 to c3 mg3
I don't know what he is playing but I'm
gonna just improve
we have a we have a kid
or I have a kid in the form of the Kings
Indian defense
I don't play the Kings Indian defense I
think c6 is a reasonable move trying to
blunt the power of the bishop also at
some point I want to develop my own
bishop
about five
efore
not shirk this is reasonable but looks
decent
he really wants to play e4 so I have a
few options I complain that e4
walking tonight h5
a
you
also thinking Queen d7
I was also thinking d5
hmm
let's play d5 25 allows 95
it's lady 5 anyway preventing e4 jack
see how you get that red circle around
that useless bishop
even though he's saying
like this
Bishop I assume like you mean this
you have to hold down shift and right
click
or just be
magician
I think there is a there's like four
different colors you can make between
this this this and this yes did them all
there might be more colors that I'm not
aware of but this is my my color
spectrum I'm gonna play b5 restricting
the Queen
realizing b5 may have not been a good
move
but it's too late now
many cases with the structure Knights
belong at least one night belongs on d6
might be difficult to do
you never knew that yeah a four is a bit
problematic its weakening to my pawn
structure
what to do
I could defend b5 somehow play a six
back upon maybe
Queen b7
let's play queen bee seven
linked the way all that all maneuver to
g6 is 94-96
or just leave my knight on e4
seems to be a decent decent square you
might play 93 and go after my bishop but
then I'm probably okay allowing this
tree getting this pawn on f5
happening
you
this is five five
okay so I don't care about writing this
won't affect rating rate clay two things
for the follow the play 94
wait a minute 94 I have to be concerned
about this stuff
I don't think it works it doesn't work
I rely on intuition again there's some
weird ideas involving either 95 or
Bishop taking 595
96
this position is not something to yawn
about
but it is a little bit energy draining
now he's attacking d5 twice probably
defend this is an ugly move but it's a
useful move
Zara's thanks for the follow
you
he's taking more time always nice to
have a time advantage
see Nation shots in the chat have you
been in the chat for a long time but did
you just get here
thanks for watching z nation Jess and
like probably my first subscriber ever
even before Nathan ons ons n1 that's an
old name
I lost to Hans and like uh and over the
board tournaments was devastating you
just completely I'll play and crush me
I'm so sad
you sent me a message a few messages
the last like the last week my inbox is
unlike every single platform have just
been ridiculous so I apologize if you
sent me a message I may have overlooked
it I may have seen it and then just got
distracted
Petre something-something thanks for the
follow I'm gonna take and then play
knight c6 because my Knights are active
and I get initiative against this Queen
this Queen has very few squares von der
is something thanks for the follow
there's so many different platforms
people message me on okay between
YouTube comments Facebook email my
website contact form leech us Twitter
discord
it can be overwhelming sometimes
Instagram
snapchat occasionally what else text
all these phone calls are the things I
receive the least
especially when traveling me rishabh
thanks for the follow
the nation was here earlier
sometimes the chat just gets out of hand
and I don't realize who's here
I don't realize losing patience here
there is a discord which is slowly
growing I think -
marius have
so it's not Mary a shot
I never notice alch as seesee that's
true also are you check is the cz like a
Czech type of name
this chat is uh it's fast-paced aren't
you keep up with probably because i
retweeted like I don't usually promotes
things on Twitter but as we just tweeted
i retweeted and everyone's joining the
stream I play B four times like Queen b6
and use blue bear for the follow
um I do play Queen b6 because this
diagonals weak and this King would have
to move somewhere awkward to the fend
also thank you jack C for the for the
hundred more bits saying something long
which I'll try and acknowledge
I made him this night is still pinned by
the way
so maybe just f6
six
you
that was generous of him yeah I don't
think he heard me when he said the
knight is pinned things can be pinned to
other pieces or they can be pinned to
squares so it's important to acknowledge
pins what chess book do I suggest
I hate answering that question because
some people will benefit from other from
different types of books also some
people learn better from videos or other
resources rather than books so I don't
like answering that question but there's
a number of good books about chess which
I'm sure other people in the check and
respond to ok
I've 33 pending challenges give me a
random number between 1 and 33
okay I found this on the web for thirty
three pennies give me a random number
between one and three you misunderstood
me give me a random number between one
and thirty three
oh and 34 okay too late I like this
number I like number one I don't have to
count Jacob but Lee one of the the
newest subs to the stream good luck
Jacob
I'll still take opening recommendations
or suggestions I'm not gonna play a perk
I'll play Knight f6 he's playing London
can I do the trap I don't think I can do
the trap
or can I I can do a variation of the
track on I don't want to disrespect him
I'll just place some normal GM GM level
stuff
is taken tonight I
okay this is take you at night there's a
funny tactic with E 5 winning a piece if
he takes with Queen this is not what
you're supposed to do in the London
usually you want to pawn on d4
but okay I still have to work
the Queen b6
might be too soon but I'm attacking
something I also want to play an ad for
an attack more things
winning with the Scotch I've actually
never heard of that book but I've heard
of Gary lame-o I can recommend another
Gary Lane book it's called find the
checkmates
maybe my last opponent could have used
that book
but find the checkmate is actually a
good book for all levels because there's
like a number of tests for from like
beginner to like international GM or
whatever and it gradually gets harder
and harder and harder
and it's all focused on checkmate which
a lot of people sometimes overlook
do i trade Queens I guess I I don't want
to just like a play queen a five
you
I thought I have a panel but I think I
think it broke and I never bothered to
fix it I was supposed to have a panel
but I don't think it links to anything I
should work on my panels good point
to look up how long it takes to get to
their ramen place
or maybe there's another rhyme in place
um
okay ramen Neera me one point six miles
okay
we actually have like a reasonable
position like he's not not dead yet
my book panel is empty that said doctor
destroyer thanks for the follow
maybe I can play e5 and trap is Bishop
always play our six
here's a square
but he also has another square okay I
was not expecting that
let's take it
so the positions get black is up a piece
for a pawn I have full domination in the
center of two bishops of a half-open I
file
not only for she's trying to destabilize
hmm
interesting
I was actually a really strong move
can I counter with a really strong move
I don't know if my c3 is really strong
but it's interesting
see what he does
maybe it's not that impressive
or maybe it is now it's
presage Nathan with the host thanks
Nathan
I hope this doesn't start like an
onslaught of just people hosting with
invites
okay night take before there's a pin is
he gonna see it
also there's three attackers on the pond
so black is now up a rook
the way I didn't see how long it takes
to get to the ramen place
one point six miles probably a half hour
walk a 15-minute run
okay we're gonna trade stuff simplify
ramen
[Music]
everything's hanging especially
checkmates okay
good game Jacob but Li like accelerating
for that even though it's rated 35
pending challenges
unless Carlson is challenging me
Carlson Carlson Carlson osseous is
challenging me
mysterious expert is challenging me oh
man I need ramen I need to get to the
ramen place before it closes and they
have like a really good like so we're
kind of weird lemonade type like I can't
even describe it but it's I need some
refreshments so I'll probably be back
and I know I'll be back maybe in a few
hours but maybe just tomorrow
so thank you everyone for subbing and
following and cheering thanks to Nathan
again for just gifting so many subs I'll
work on thinking about emotes but people
can people can join my discord Channel
and and there's a channel for emotes
which i think is completely empty people
can uh or maybe it's not completely
empty but people can still loose their
suggestions there so I mean I'm gonna
end it there thanks guys and maybe I'll
be back maybe I won't but I'm definitely
gonna uh be going for ramen right now so
bye